la police a peur peur de ces autonome du
chanteur bloc militants d'extrême gauche
qui pour la violence n'ont rien à envier
à l'extrême droite depuis les années 80
une nouvelle technique de manifestation
est née en allemagne les blocs noirs
les black blocks le but agir en restant
groupés de façon anonyme
au départ une volonté défendre des
squats de berlin ouest
mais rapidement le combat s'élargit et
s'internationalise 1999 les black blocks
au mouvement anarchiste et
anticapitalistes se montre au grand jour
pour la première fois ils sont
médiatisés l'histoire retiendra que le
couvre feu a été instauré dans les rues
de seattle au soir de l'ouverture du
sommet de l'om c'est impossible de
dresser le profil type pad hiérarchie
pas d'organisation mais un courant
politique semble les rassembler
l'anarchisme révolutionnaire des fausses
un distributeur de billets on est
vraiment dans le symbole sont des
contraintes dire voilà le système qu'on
préconise c'est un système dans lequel
des français on a un distributeur de
billets des fossés le mans s'est rappelé
au monde qu'à l'heure actuelle on roule
génère de la richesse que dans le sang
le clou pour en faire du profit donc il
faut dire stop
il faut dire arrêtons ça et la meilleure
façon de le dire c'est de rentrer dans
le tas dès que c'est possible c'est pas
en avons manifesté en baisse d'un point
à un autre à 500 millions
les actions violentes de guérilla
urbaine sans chan à chaque sommet de
chefs d'état pour lutter contre la
mondialisation avec toujours cette
volonté de rester anonyme
exemple en 2009 à strasbourg lors du
sommet de l'otan
en fin d'après-midi la police à la
recherche de casseurs filtre la
dispersion des derniers manifestants
quelques mètres avant ce barrage voici
ce que nous découvrons une multitude de
vêtements noirs et des protège tibias
les black blocks ont tout abandonné sur
place la plupart sont probablement
sortis sans être inquiété mais au fil
des ans les black blocks investissent
aussi d'autres combats comme les adh par
exemple à notre dame des landes
cette violence venant de cet ultra
gauche de ces blacks blocs qui sont
souvent originaires de notre pays mais
aussi de pays étrangers est inadmissible
notre dame des landes sivens loi
travailler maintenant gilet jaune
les black blocks sont de toutes les
manifestations avec la même technique
que dans les années 80 faire bloc
sahnouni miser et s'attaquer aux
symboles du pouvoir
[Musique]